thank you very much for inviting me and
thank you all for coming in this
afternoon session so I was thinking
about first of all if I'm a little
incoherent because amoz deadline was
last night some of us who or papers
farmers are probably in the same state
so there's a question about what to
present in the sense that there's a
number of collaborators in the room who
have seen the stock many times before
and if you choose to read your email
that's perfectly fine but I've decided
to just give you a quick overview
focusing more on the applications since
this is a workshop focused on game
theory and practice so there's a large
number of collaborators because it's
going to be expand talking about the
entire range of work on security games
in the room are Vince Tomas Kevin Albert
hopefully I'm not forgetting somebody
and we have lots and lots of
collaborators and lots of students and
postdocs the current team up so given
the large number of collaborators and
highlight the role of key students and
postdocs as we go through the
presentation so let's start with the
basic premise here security is a global
concern we have to protect our ports and
airports it redic the illegal flow of
drugs weapons and money suppress urban
crime protect forests fish and wildlife
in all of these cases we have limited
security resources and a large number of
targets to protect and watchful
adversary you can monitor our defenses
and exploit any patterns so the question
becomes how do you schedule or plan or
allocate limited resources and we appeal
two games here in particular model
called the Stackelberg security games
now some of you are very familiar with
this model but for the benefit of those
who may not be I'm going to use a very
small example and run through it very
quickly so this is two by two ty example
of the US Coast Guard trying to protect
the port made up of two targets and in
this case target one happens to be more
important than target too now we know
that Coast Guard are out there first
patrolling if they commit to a pure
strategy all
trying to protect one of the targets the
adversary can exploit that however if
the Coast Guard were to commit to a
mixed strategy randomized strategy sixty
percent of the time that a target one
for division of the finder at target to
an adversary conducting surveillance
will only know that the Coast Guard are
here sixty percent there forty percent
but what they'll do tomorrow remains
unpredictable the goal here is only to
increase the cost and uncertainty two
attackers in coming up with a plan of
attack the point being that we are not
guaranteeing a hundred percent security
because there is no such thing in the
real world we are optimizing the use of
our limited resources and these kinds of
games are Stackelberg gains because
security forces commit first they are
out in the open the adversaries conduct
surveillance and then they respond and
the challenge for us I mean in this case
it's a two by two games 6040 is it a
60-40 allocation should it be a 70-30
allocation of course we can solve this
by hand but when it comes to trillions
of possible patrolling strategies large
numbers of targets solving these games
by hand becomes difficult and that's
where our contributions have been in
terms of solving massive scale games
under uncertainty so this was sort of
the first set of applications we built
that came out of this work were all
focused on infrastructure security so
the US Coast Guard for example is using
solutions to what we've done to generate
patrols in ports like Boston and New
York and Los Angeles in Houston so
that's a you know taking into account
rates of targets in the port or the
patrols around the Staten Island Ferry
are also generated using these
Stackelberg game models with the TSA our
work was to assign air marshals two
flights on randomized basis taking into
account risks of the flight so this is
again salt as it's not a working model
I'll talk to you about how this all
works work all started this was at the
LAX international airport setting up
checkpoints and k 9 patrols of airport
on a randomized basis the work has gone
on Argentina bunis Irish Airport
patrolling we take our own medicines
like USC are assigning patrols resolve
done in the same way the LA Sheriff's
Department that's something that I've so
these are all deployed this has been
tested and so forth so this is what we
have done in the past please
so entirely understand the motivation
for the staff Bob or the solution it's a
mixed strategy I mean so I mean if
you're mixing over lots of possibilities
are you assuming somehow that the
attackers know you're there
so I mean let me just proceed so I can
you can you can see you can see what's
going on here just momentarily and so
where we are going next here is with the
green security so this is a
collaboration with an thera World
Wildlife on the non-governmental
organizations for protection of wildlife
endangered wildlife or with the Coast
Guard for protection of Fisheries in the
Gulf of Mexico and this is collaboration
with IBM to try to ensure that we can do
randomized inspections of factories that
might be polluting rivers now what's new
here is the fact that here we have
unfortunately a lot of data because
there's a lot of poaching attacks a lot
of illegal fishing going on and as a
result we can learn adversary models
from the data and then we can improve
our strategies and play again so it
becomes like a repeated game what's also
interesting here is that we can now
bring in insights from conservation
biology and criminology and so we now
have a conference of C's computation
conservation and criminology that we've
been holding for the past two years
there's a domain where there is even
more data than this and that's a
opportunistic crime so we have data from
inner around us see unfortunately we are
in part of LA where there's a lot of
crime and so for the past three we have
data for example for the past several
years that gives us data from from the
space that allows us to learn adversary
models so there's not fortunately not a
whole lot of data here we start getting
medium amounts of data here and then
lots of data here and so this leads to
some very different research challenges
challenges in exploration versus
exploitation here for example some of
our colleagues have tried to push all of
this into cyber security that's not our
work but that work does exist and i'm
not going to talk about it so you are
see did a nice magazine article front on
our work pointing out some of the
deployments it was nice to see some of
these deployments spreading outside the
US because of our partnerships with the
ngos and all of this is possible because
of us embedding with the different
security agent
seas with the Coast Guard so me my
students postdocs collaborators working
closely with these agencies trying to
understand local constraints in the
process our students having to learn a
whole new kind of cutting plane
algorithms that they didn't think that
they would have to learn in computer
science so more recently with all of
this in 2012 or so I competed in a USC
competition to win startup funds based
on which I launched a start-up armor way
there's a moment of panic right after
launching when HD students quit their
jobs to join the startup but now they're
running it and it's doing very well it's
growing and so it's a very exciting time
in terms of the security games work and
where it's going with it so in the rest
of this presentation i'll start with the
infrastructure security games sort of
giving you a quick overview focusing
mostly on applications and just sort of
telegraphing key technical challenges
and I'll come to your question as we so
all of the work has been published in AI
conferences triple aah gaya mas and so
forth so there's the standard evaluation
that you see in those papers but since
we are fortunate that a lot of this work
is deployed in the real world there's
also evaluation that we must do in the
real world and here I really just ask
for your patience I will get to it in
the last 10 minutes but I just need need
to go through the rest of the stuff
before i get to the evaluation so let's
start with the first which is a LX which
was our first system called armor and
this is the basic Stackelberg security
game model that we have so that the
problem started with the arrows others
who is an assistant chief or airport
police at the time being concerned about
security at LAX his concern was I back
something like this somebody attacking
the this Glasgow Airport attack somebody
ramming a truck full of explosives or
vehicle-borne improvised explosive
device at the airport now he talked to
us about the extensive surveillance that
happens of these kinds of settings so
that the adversities get to know the
security measures he talked to us about
maps surveillance maps of western
airports being found on computers
confiscated in Pakistan from terrorists
and so there's sort of this idea that
there's a lot of surveillance going on
and so based on this at the time it just
seemed like a good idea 2006 Vincent
Domas had written this paper on
Stackelberg games it's arrow had asked
us you know how do i schedule and plan
and allocate and so based on this armor
was launched and so there's 18 bound
roads into LX but not enough officers
who have checkpoints on all roads at all
times a terminals not enough dogs to be
at all terminals at all times so where
and when do you schedule checkpoints
where and when do drills and so we do
solve this problem using stackelberg a
model sometimes it leads to RS a lot of
people as you see there and so the same
so we call this the basic game model
because i'll just keep enhancing it the
exact
a model is in use in Buena Cyrus Airport
this is work done by initiative you know
Cyrus as I said also at USC and so how
does this work to begin with we take
entire game matrix we feed it into a
mixed-integer program the mixed integer
program provides us a probability
distribution or your strategy so for
example is saying do a k9 patrol at 8am
at terminals to five and six k9 patrol
at 8am its terminals three five and
seven with the different probabilities
and then we sample from this
distribution to get an actual schedule
that gets executed by the police
officers and this is the actual schedule
that gets handed over to the officers so
saying at 8am send team 1 to terminal 2
team 5 from terminal three teams 5 4
terminal 6 and so on please oh I was
just going to talk to you in a minute
that's a very good question just one
second and so let me just go through the
mixed integer program and I'll kind of
quickly go through this we are trying to
maximize defender expected utility rij
is the reward to the defender if the
defender takes strategy i and the
adversary takes a strategy j excise the
probability with which we execute a
particular strategy now here we are
enumerated every possible allocation of
defender resources to target so x1 is
the probability that there is a dog on
terminal one dog on terminal 2 x 2 is
the probability there's a dog on
terminal to a dog on terminal 3 this
works for small problems like LAX it
soon runs into trouble as you will
shortly see QJ is the address that is
best response now so we can solve this
problem but the question is exactly how
do you know that package payoffs and so
here at LAX the threat was somebody
driving a truck bomb into one of the
terminals and so based on that the idea
is there is great data available on how
many people are there at different times
of the day at different terminals and so
we look at that as a measure of civilian
casualties and that becomes our pay off
later on I'm going to talk to you about
an application we developed for the US
Coast Guard so there's a team or tea
that have gone to every single major
port in the United States for every
single target that they could find for
every single method of attack that they
could think of they say how many people
will die and what will be the economic
consequences multiplying life by million
dollars or some number of million
dollars you get a single number for each
target is called the risk index number
and there's sort of lots and lots of
this detailed data that's available and
that's what we are reading as our payoff
matrix now we understand that this is
not perfect so we have to handle
uncertainty and I'll come to that a
little bit later on but with all of this
in place by 2008 armor was at work at
LAX given this and other enhancements
that Errol had made to the LAX airport
he gave a testimony before a
congressional subcommittee hearing and
we're going to play a small clip from
this testimony as a as shown here LAX to
save it today than it was 18 months ago
the team of research led by dr. molentel
may work with our department develop
armor by the way if you don't know at
all he was nominee number one Obama
President Obama's nominee to head the
TSA the first nominee we were very
fortunate he declined stayed at USC and
so he's now a great friend and so but
around the same time Newsweek had this
article armor throws a digital cloak of
invisibility which led my colleagues at
omas next year to ask me how our
cloaking device research at USC was
coming along this led us to be contacted
by the Federal Air Marshal Service and
their challenge is assigning air
marshals to flights now armor 100
actions iris we're looking at certainly
thousand flights a day assigning air
marshals with just 20 air marshals back
shun space force 10 to the power 41 just
going back to the for example in your
toy example at the very beginning like
the action space of the defender in the
actual space of the attacker were the
same here i guess it's less obvious to
me it seems like the action space of the
attacker would be something like what
point do I one attack
actually space defender is where do I
station people four checkpoints right so
right right so that first yeah the first
time example you know there's only one
resource if you have to then the
defender action space starts to grow
because now you're looking at all
possible combinations and so if you have
20 air marshals let's a thousand flights
then you're looking at all possible
assignment trick did you have to in
addition to designing the payoffs of the
attackers you also have to just think
about designing what the strategy space
looks like or how did you do that with
it in this case I mean they're sort of a
natural allocation for the defenders for
example you know we check which roads
are we going to set up checkpoints on
there are eight roads I don't know if
that's the question you're asking but
Reddick it was it the same the
strategies face of the attackers
attacker is just going to go attack one
terminal for example in that example
right right and here to the action space
of the attackers more constrained I'll
come to an example where it's more
complex just in a minute gone a little
more about how you choose which I mean I
is it unique yes yes yeah your
strategies oh isn't it well we are
looking for me it's it's well I mean you
can have multiple but it'll get to the
same pay same payoff you find the same
so that's a great question so if you
just wait a little bit you'll see
techniques where we start to try to deal
with the fact that you know we need to
be more robust to uncertainty just
so maybe you want to defer the students
kind of related but you mean aside I
realize this may be hard to answer
empirically but what's your sense for
how much of what's important here is
actually solving for a game here at
equilibrium versus just introducing the
uncertainty of randomness that's a
that's a really really great question
and the last 10 minutes of my talk I
promise I'll come to some of that and
I'm noggin adapter so much as strategy
and banish all questions and just
continue on with my talk yes so the
basic point here was that we feed this
input into armor and it quietly dies
running out of memory because the game
is so large so we needed incremental
strategy generation column generation
basically the idea is to not enumerate
all the 10 to the power 41 different
defender strategies here and so I'm just
going to very quickly yesterday it
seemed like baby forcing like people
were just saying column generation
everybody understood what was going on
so that's what I'm going to say so you
start with a master program that just
has a few strategies and then master
slip decomposition you iterate and
finally the global optimal you get
instead of having 10 to the power 41
strategies we may just have like a 500
rogue a matrix so you may find a global
optimal without enumerate in all the
different defender strategies and that's
the way in which these games get solved
we haven't solved the largest possible
such games but this is taken us a long
way and this is the way the Irish
program got built is delivered to the
air marshals 2009 they started deploying
it it significantly changed the fams
operation if you've been on an
international air flight by US air
carrier whether there was an Air Marshal
on your flight or not may have been
determined by this program in 2012 in a
congressional subcommittee hearing again
they talked about our work USC project
with fans on randomizing flights and so
forth so we were we were thrilled with
this around the same time though you may
recall or not there was an attack on
Mumbai
and so you know to last week when
there's an attack in Paris they said
it's a Mumbai style attack well I grew
up in Mumbai and it's unfortunate that
mean that's what Mumbai is known for now
but I grew up maybe three blocks away
from this hotel and so in one of my
trips back I saw checkpoints being set
up by the police and so these are
supposed to be these randomized
checkpoints and the question was after
coming back the USC can we solve for the
entire city of Mumbai to set up
checkpoints on a randomized fashion
using game theory principles and so this
was work we did with wins and we could
show that we can set up 15 checkpoints
20,000 roads in a program under 20
minutes using a double Oracle approach
so I was thrilled with this we can solve
generator randomized checkpoints I went
to the Mumbai police headquarters to
present it I felt like as part of a
Bollywood movie but it was really hard
because these people are not believers
in game theory at all and so it was
really really difficult questioning but
the dialogue continues and so we will
see where this goes next we started
working with the US Coast Guard and we
developed the system called protect you
protect is an acronym this is just to
tell you that we spend a lot of time
coming up with good acronyms so this was
a start this first set of patrols was
implemented in Boston taking into
account weights of different argit's can
you generate patrols what the Coast
Guard were concerned about threats like
these summary doing a suicide boat
launch and the port today protect is
deployed in New York and Los Angeles in
Houston potentially going to other ports
in the country in 2012 after Boston was
deployed and they saw our progress they
made a small video I'm going to play a
small clip from the video they made for
us the result was invigorated boat
cruise more focused upon providing
effective presence reducing
predictability and enhancing
safety and security within our ports
protect guided patrols became a source
of pride for station Boston crews and it
doesn't get much better than that
protect is also that other positive side
effects such as the development of
better tactics techniques and procedures
the results have been exceptional and so
the other part of protect this besides
sort of patrolling the ports is patrols
around the staten island ferry carrying
sixty thousand passengers a day the
Coast Guard think the threat is somebody
launching about suicide brought into the
ferry so they turn these patrols around
the Staten Island Ferry so these are
actually our algorithms at work around
the failure and so when there is a
appreciation from the public about the
Coast Guard patrols around the ferry the
Coast Guard tell us it's good for us and
that's that's that's another system
that's been implemented I'm going to
talk to you a little bit about how this
scale of works because it's slightly
different from the column generation
approach and we're going to talk to you
in terms of use of marginals here to
scale up and I'm going to use a discrete
state time represent space-time
representation although there's a
continuous-time version of it albert
who's sitting here is one of the
principal architects of the system so
you can jump in but essentially this
three locations ABC 5 10 three time
points so you can see a ferry here going
from C to B to a jumping from one point
to another point a redbox is any place
where an attacker could attack the ferry
and so we can run patrols like the green
patrol from B to C to B to try to
protect this ferry so if a patrol is
near a fairy it can protect it so we can
solve this problem just like we did
before to generate a randomized patrol
strategy over all the possible routes
where we take the roots as variables in
this case there are n to the power t
variables who say n is the number of
locations these the amount of time
slices so that's the total number of
groups this doesn't scale but if we were
to instead of taking roots as variables
take probability flows over segments so
take for example this green segment and
the brown segment combine it together
and single probability flow
variable these two combined into a
single probability for flow variable now
you have n squared multiplied by T
variables for smaller number of
variables you can scale this up you can
get the probabilities you want to run
these patrols so this is how the Staten
Island Ferry program was built in 2013
we were unfortunate that the Coast Guard
mentioned our work in the Congressional
subcommittee hearing we're working with
the University of Southern California to
utilize game theory as a way of
optimizing and scheduling our patrol so
this is just so that people who
appreciate game theory field happy that
gets here is being appreciated so now
let's talk about handling of uncertainty
here I talked about trains in Los
Angeles is a barrier we have a
barrier-free trains as the meaning
people can get on and off the train
without purchasing a ticket so the LA
Sheriff's Department does a randomized
patrol check again this is work done
with Kevin Tomas and others and so we
first generated using our Staten Island
Ferry type IX representation schedule
which is written on paper you know that
generates scheduled second 913 a and
start checking people on this station
for fare evasion 923 get on the next
train start checking people for fare
evasion and on and on on goes the
patrols where the schedules already
patrols already our students go on with
the officers to start the patrols and
922 just before the train arrives the
officer says I have to take a bathroom
break now what do you do I mean we don't
read in provision for a bathroom break
in our Stackelberg equilibrium so but
the more important interruption happens
when they arrest people when because it
takes a lot of time to process people so
we needed to handle the fact that there
is uncertainties in this process so even
though we want the probability flow of
point three there is a small chance that
the officer may remain at station B and
so this can be done by integrating MDPs
into the security game frameworks
basically each pure strategies mdp
policy and then you can load these
policies on to smartphones so there's
always an action available to the
officer even if there is an interruption
now this is just one example of the kind
of certainty we talked earlier about all
kinds of uncertainties the payoffs may
not be exactly maybe interval
uncertainty how much surveillance is
going on how much execution uncertainty
does exist how much adversary
rationality I mean you know so there's
all kinds of questions here and we've
been working on these lots of theses
being written with different algorithms
that focus on all these different kinds
of uncertainties I'm not going to go
have time to go into all of this but
there's a lot of work that's been
focused on trying to build more robust
algorithms that are robust all these
different kinds of uncertainties but
since I have limited time let me move on
to the latest topic that we've been
working on which is green security games
this work started with the US Coast
Guard trying to protect the Gulf of
Mexico from illegal fishermen who come
from across the border into the u.s.
exclusive economic zone so we've built
this system they have done these patrols
the software is with them we'll see
where it goes with an NGO in Madagascar
and our colleagues at Michigan State
University we are working on forest
protection in that country and so this
is again trying to protect forests from
illegal loggers with IBM india the
problem is people who pollute rivers for
example the ganga river is a important
river apparently there is research going
on that says if the river has some
intrinsic quality so the water purifies
itself and so forth but unfortunately is
not true it's the fifth dirtiest river
in the world and it's because there's a
lot of people who pollute the factories
and so the question is can we generate
randomized inspections of these
factories but the part that I really
want to focus on here today is work on
wildlife protection this is murcheson
Falls National Park Uganda we have a
number of collaborators around the world
this is the Wildlife Conservation
Society some of you may have been in
yoga and I know kevin has been there
here but it's a it's a gorgeous place
lots of absolutely wonderful animals but
there's threats to this wildlife these
are snares that poachers plays for
example this one here the way it works
is that they open it up the jaws put it
in the ground
if an animal steps on it gets captured
then a poacher comes and kills the
animal these are wire snares there's
thousands of these this is just captured
from 2014 and this is me with the head
of security they're pointing to the loss
that happens because of this for example
elephants walking with their trunks cut
off so the way they try to maintain
security in this parks is that they'll
go out they'll send people out in patrol
for some period of time the patrollers
will go out collect data in terms of
snares or human poaching signs and so
forth all of that will come back to
headquarters they'll analyze the data
and then send patrollers back again into
the field so we can look at it as a
repeated Stackelberg games here for
example we've divided the forest area to
grid each grid cell is a target targets
with more water or more important
because there's more animals there and
now the defender is generating going to
generate a mixed strategy they're going
to execute patrols when poachers
attacked we get data from which we can
learn adversary models and that will
allow us to them improve our defender
strategies so we have a lot of data that
we are getting from the field for
example we have 12 years of data from
Uganda talk a little bit about that
later but to speed up the process of
getting data we've also built this
system on amt for a game to have humans
act as poachers and come attack our
algorithm so here we've divided the park
into a grid the it's more green it's not
as well protected people can attack it
more easily if it's more red there's a
lot more patrol hyper patrol probability
and so higher danger of being captured
which show hippos to show now how
important a cell is we use hippos
because it's a non charismatic species
so people wouldn't feel as guilty to
poach and then we play we generate
defender strategies and we play games
against them this is the play for your
money on amt of course and so they can
go to different parts and see if they're
successful what they would get if they
fail what they would get probability of
success and fame
failure and then they can if they
succeed in snaring they get real money
if they fail they lose real money so
we've been playing these games now for
several years trying to collect data on
how people act in these games and what
we notice of course is that I mean if we
assume that people who are acting by
calculating expected utility exactly
techno means okay good it's not good but
yeah so let me let me speed up well we
all know that the perfect rationality
model it doesn't work people just don't
just attack one cell that has the
highest expected utility what we find is
that a cuanto response model assuming
that the adversaries are acting
according to this cuanto response model
meaning cells that have higher expected
utility they are more likely to attack
cells that have lower expected utility
they're less likely protect and then
calculating our defender strategies
against that tends to work better you're
not just learning you're not just
learning their strategy you're actually
trying to learn how they're going to
respond to your strategy that's right
that's right so if you're learning in
this case we are learning this lambda
for this model and in games that we've
played this quadrant response more so
this is just showing different for
different games y axis is defendant
expected reward lower is worse higher is
better and here assuming perfect
rationality leads to far worse results
then assuming the dyad Viserys are
playing with the quantum response but
this is our first attempt we found that
there's a model that can do even better
than cuanto response and this week all
subjective utility qantas was
essentially the ideas that people are
taking the capture probability reward
and penalty has three different features
rather than combining them in any
fashion and then we learn the weight on
these different features of different
targets and then if you look at the use
the quantum response formulation to
calculate the subjective expected
utility and from that the probability
that tends to work even better and so
this is not just in human subject
experiments if we match it with data
from Uganda this is for year 2012 this
is an ROC curve this corner going
towards this corner is better and is
showing that we can match with the suq
our model get a better accuracy in
predicting where poachers are attacking
than with other competing
models from from our literature we can
do even better so this is paper that was
submitted to a mess last night for
Uganda so this is a system we've built
for Uganda for life conservation society
showing that we can do continue to
improve our model of how the addresses
behave based on real-world data so I'm
going to skip all of this in the
interest of time so there's a lot more
lots of very interesting phenomena we
found that our model in our data human
perception of probability is exactly the
opposite how Kahneman and Tversky find
it in prospect theory so bears says
people over very low probability and
under way high probability and we find
people seem to not care about low
probability and really care about
slightly high probability and so this is
something very interesting we submitted
a paper to a IJ based on this and the
reviewers are not happy they really want
us that really really really show that
this is true so we will see but all of
this is led to a system called pause now
this is for patrolling the forest for
protection of wildlife this was deployed
in Uganda this is with the Andrew lamu
doing these patrols this was then tried
out in Malaysia with panthera this is
them finding a porter scamp on one of
the patrols but the feedback was that
you know you guys are not paying
attention to geography and so they would
keep telling us in Malaysia the shortest
distance between two points is not a
straight line which was made no sense
and so we all of us flew to Malaysia to
see how that would work so that's me my
student Fay a former postdoc belong at
the beginning of the patrol in the
forest in Malaysia to see what is going
on so we were hacking our way through
the forest found a poacher's camp at the
end of eight hours that's our state
completely exhausted but we did
understand the shortest distance between
two points is not a straight line in the
forest it's a Ridgeline you have to walk
along the ridgeline to preserve energy
and so if you look at the forest in
google maps here you can see there's a
hidden
eat map in the forest if you walk along
rivers streams and regionalize it works
so this is how we can generate patrol
paths so this is somewhat of sort of AI
planning problem to find roots in this
in this forest region use that to
generate patrols and that's what we now
do and so there is a power system people
are out there out today in Malaysia in
the forest patrolling generating this
output of pause so I'll skip this crime
model and get to the question that I
wanted to answer in five minutes okay
and so this is how to evaluate these
systems so our claim is that the
security games lead to significant
improvement over how humans were
planning these sorts of activities for
optimizing security resources and we've
shown this humans or other kinds of
tools that were being used in the past
and we've shown this using evaluation in
the lab simulations human addresses
we've gone out in the field and measured
patrol quality before and after are our
patrols more are our patrols more
unpredictable do they cover the right
kinds of targets we've run scheduling
computations humans vs game theory we've
also gone out in the field and tried to
catch the bad guys if you will to see
who does a better job and in with all of
these we are able to show that the
software the security game base its
decision in least a significant
improvement over the state of the art
which is either human schedulers or
simple tools that were being used now
I'm going to show you some very quick
data and support of the humans fail
because it's just a very high cognitive
load in these systems and so I'm just
going to show you some quick data these
are actual patrols from Boston done by
human beings to try to patrol the border
bus and this is days of the week y axis
is count how frequently was a target
visited so this is one particular target
how frequently was it visited over many
weeks on day 1 day 2 etc there's two
points to note here first there's very
few patrols on day 2 of the week a good
day to attack the port secondly all
these lines crisscross meaning sometimes
the target is more important sometimes
there's no simple no not important there
is no systematic way to give way to
these targets this is the patrols after
protect less important targets are
visited less frequently more important
targets are visited more frequently
there's no dip one day to etc and any on
any given day whether the boat will go
unpredictable but overall the higher
targets important targets get visited
more if you look at it from a defender
expected utility perspective which we
are familiar with there's the three
hundred and fifty percent increase in a
defender expected utility from before to
after there's also a test that the fams
ran six months human versus our software
who does a better job scheduling and
there's all kinds of detailed
statistical tests I've only seen it once
in the Moores hi you know like a
high-security session where they showed
me that data but it's sitting there with
them but there's a GAO report if you
want to see what are the weaknesses of
human schedulers is a criticism of it
but it was after this six-month
competition that they realized that the
humans take a lot of time and do a worse
job scheduling and therefore the
security gains approach is better we
also ran a competition humans vs game
theory schedule 90 officers on trains in
LA these are pictures from that day and
we had neutral people who didn't know
which schedule was which trying to mark
who did a better job scheduling and
there were 12 questions they were asked
and in the end what we found his humans
took a day that generate a schedule and
their schedule were marked worse than
what we did and so this is the red line
is the answers from the observers and
patrol quality of our software versus
what was done by humans there's a mark
attacker team deployed in Boston by the
Coast Guard before to after so these are
like people acting like terrorists if
you will trying to say which was a
better patrol in their conclusion was
that before to after protect deterrence
it improved there are additional
real-world indicators from Boston
boaters questioning has the Coast Guard
recently acquired more boats in fact the
number of hours our operation has gone
down but there was a parent some more
boats being on the water we actually
went and did a test of game theory vs
random schedule so this gets to making
questions on who you know who would do a
better job catching ferry
so officers for 21 days had to patrol
they didn't know which schedule was
which once was using game theory once
was using a pure random and that to go
out now this is a real test is a real
officer sketching real people and so our
students were going along with them on
every patrol and so the officer said I
don't like this schedule I want to go
somewhere else there's no way for us to
say you cannot do that not a student
who's sitting in over the with the LA
Sheriff's Department so he said if you
don't like it if you want to go
somewhere else that's fine and so in
fact what I in the 21 days of patrol we
kept the conditions as identical as
possible it turned out that whenever
they were given a uniform random
schedule at some points they would say
well I don't like this I want to go to
another place where I know there are
more fairy waiters and I can go catch
them so we let them do that but this
only happened whenever there was a
uniform random schedule they interrupted
whenever there's a game-theoretic
schedule they were happy with it at the
end of 21 days if you look at the
capture rate per 30 minutes you will
find that the game theory schedule led
to a sixty percent improvement in put in
capture rate of fare evaders this is a
not controlled test at LAX this is
before to after armor getting deployed
and the arrest rate went up but this is
not a control test because they may have
been other kinds of things going on so I
know I should wrap up this is me
boasting but in the interest of science
I hope you'll forgive me I look at this
as user feedback in terms of different
commendations from the city and the
Coast Guard and so forth at our group
has received so that's it for us we feel
that there is a tremendous amount of
research yet to be done so the answer to
many of your questions I can already
tell you research is yet to be done many
theses have yet to be written for the
sake of my PhD students who don't have a
thesis topic yet yes there is a lot of
work but we are very happy to see all
kinds of other applications or paper at
triple-a I 16 we'll talk about our work
that's starting with the TSA to improve
screening a checkpoint and so this is
something that may get implemented so
we'll see how this moves forward but
there's audit games the software testing
there's just a lots of exciting things
to
so I thank by ending my sponsors at
Homeland Security Center TSA Army
Research Office in the US Coast Guard
thank you questions before so I I wanted
to get your maybe thoughts on on the
general approach of security this is not
not a criticism of your work in general
but usually what we see when security
sales is that attackers of some have
found a way to work outside of our model
checkpoints in LAX they're not just
driving a car bomb but then maybe drive
a vehicle first to see if there's a if
there's our own book and the car bomb
will follow if the first able distance
yes so sometimes we might be worried
about things going outside our model do
you have any thoughts on how to improve
models so I guess the first got a first
question was answered that is that we
are not I mean we cannot provide one
hundred percent security that's just not
going to happen and in fact initially
when we presented this work people were
saying why don't you do a red team test
send a red team see if they can break
through the checkpoints or not and I
would go and present it to arrow and I
was at all said this is nonsense if you
ask a dedicated group of people to go
find a hole at LAX and go attack it they
will find it no matter how much the
security that that's not the question
the question is have you increased the
cost to the attacker so that they might
now go to a lower value target for you
and if we ask that question then I think
there is an improvement there now yes if
so you know if they have you throw a
one-truck if they bring in six trucks
you know that's it we're done but at
least now we've increased their cost so
that's kind of the general answer in
general the way this whole thing is work
is that there's a human being who's
doing this job it's a boring job it's a
complicated job if you imagine somebody
scheduling for the air marshals there's
thousands of flights there's duty hours
off hours people have to be brought in
they go somewhere else they have to be
brought in you can't leave an Air
Marshal outside the US so all these
complicated things so they come up with
a schedule after all this scheduling is
done we say you're not random
if you need to be random it's very hard
for a human being to douala and the
software is just better at it your talk
at least you've taken the game matrix
essentially as fixed both in terms of
the payoffs and the strategies and I'm
wondering if your techniques here could
inform about what types of things are
easier to protect so like if I wanted to
expand my conservation and Africa could
I expand it in a way that would minimize
poaching so so I guess the way this
works right now is that we go out with
patrol will collect data the idea is
that that data will then allow us to
improve our weights on the on the
different features of the game that the
you could take a more mechanism designer
/ ocean change the game you could you
could do a better feature selection if
your model is not somehow you know
getting a good enough prediction
accuracy you could try and figure out
what might be going wrong and and
there's all kinds of other questions but
I guess at this point we are not working
on dynamic games and so for mean you
know this work I don't know Ariel pro
Katya and so forth are looking at
learning game matrices from scratch by
playing different strategies and then so
forth so that's also a direction / we
haven't we haven't gone into that area
yet siga one more question just to maybe
take my question forward alphabet you
haven't just qualitative to say about
okay so not your randomization but about
the structure of your solution so for
example your Boston solution it kind of
looked like you were covering in some
propulsion and then you do that randomly
right right right so not on the current
value of game theory here but no no I
think I think this was exactly the
question Kevin asked me maybe you talk
to him anyway this was exactly so I've
been thinking about that and we are we
are now trying to really try to
no further research on this tub you but
the way to think about it is that in the
end we are trying to optimize against an
adversary so we're trying to see how can
we optimize our limited resources
against the unintelligent adversary and
so we need some kind of a model of the
adversary now all that if you look at
once you have once you get into domains
urban crime wildlife crime there's tons
of data available from which we learn
the model so that's the model that we
are optimizing again so that's that's
clear the when we come to things like
protecting airports and ports there
isn't data so we end up relying on
expert knowledge in terms of how what
they think and their general assessment
is that these adversaries are very
strategic they are doing very careful
surveillance arrow has a whole chapter
on the kind of surveillance that gets
done and you know the planning cycle and
the surveillance cycle and so the idea
is then that yes there is a significant
amount of surveillance going on and
therefore we have to optimize to to us
to an assumption that the adversaries
are really very strategic but obviously
if they are not and we if we don't have
any data then what we want is a solution
that is as robust as possible even if
they are not at that extreme scale and
so that's something that we are trying
to do research on to see is there you
know can we measure that can we see
which of the algorithms have more
tolerance to or less tolerance that
Scylla hopefully that gets to some of
what my cousin see stop their thang